[Music]
now Brendan's coming back at Dana White
not just on the fighter and the kid
Marsh he did a five minute a tight five
on Dana
for his stand-up set can I before you
hit play why are his pants so tight I
don't know bro
why
and I asked this off the air
so Brendan's entire identity and his
whole branding is basically MMA bro
culture yes and the majority of the
guests he's able to get are by and large
MMA fighters both current and retired
yeah especially that food truck [ __ ] for
sure huge huge huge like overlap with
MMA so he's picking a fight
with the single most powerful man in the
world of mixed martial arts yes
that's a bold street by the way let's
see if it pays off the gentleman who
still pays Joe Rogan a lot of money to
do commentating all because he just went
that makes sense that's it
Dana White hates me
for no reason no listen I hate you and I
have a lot of reasons never met you and
I yeah
I didn't he's a good guy man
nothing dude how dare you for those of
you that don't know he called me
thick with three C's that way sagora
can't sue on his shirt
Tommy and I'm 39 years old oh the shirt
says save a horse ride a thick boy
who comes up with his terrible he does
he's an idiot
[ __ ] dummy dude I can't just lay down
like you're right like you can't do that
dude you're dummy you're a dummy you're
a dummy and you've been laying down for
us over and over again you [ __ ] dummy
and then you called him a dummy back
and then basically said that it's it's
not [ __ ] rocket science it's a
[ __ ] it's a brain surgery to run a
billion dollar co-organ I could run the
I I could run it sure I could run it I
could run the UFC yeah easy no problem
easy peasy what do you got to do you
gotta you gotta waste some people set up
some fights I already made this I've
made this joke once before Brendan but
the only thing you're good at running is
Theo Vaughn out of your life [ __ ] it
back you're good at running field on
back to the Bayou
[ __ ] he's gonna be Bryce yeah you
[ __ ] it dude [ __ ] Theo Von hates you
so much he's [ __ ] somewhere
crawfishing right now yeah he's moving
he's moving back into his she's moving
back into his trailer next next door to
[ __ ] Joe Dirt
it's like out there in a kayak [ __ ]
frog gigging yeah man I should have
never gone to L.A man it was [ __ ]
stupid I'm better out here I love Theo
crushing Bush lights in a [ __ ] canoe
it's like oh man [ __ ] yeah those guys
were so gay
dude it's not nice why would you get so
upset if my theory on UFC 279 is so
outlandish what theory why so why why
are you just no I know I know because we
cover him I know but he's doing this at
a stand-up at a stand-up gig and he's
not filling people in he's not giving
Cliff Notes so he's like yeah he called
me a [ __ ] dummy and it's like what
what if I was wrong about UFC Tuesday I
assume I don't I didn't see that episode
of your show he thinks as many people
are tuned into this as they were as to
the Will Smith you know Kid Rock Chris
Rock slap where everyone knows about
that look except for us because we like
making fun of you and some MMA people
the average person's not going to know
about your little beef with Dana White
I'm sure Ariel helwani got a little
chuckle out of it today yeah that was
about it on another note Dana White
thought it was somebody else at first
yeah he was going off about the other
guy and he said he's a [ __ ] dummy and
he's brain dead and then he was like
I'll be your huckleby
no if you remember what Dana White said
it's like [ __ ] most of what he was
saying is like this is [ __ ]
ridiculous because this guy knows the
you know the [ __ ] the back end of
this [ __ ] and [ __ ] as soon as it was
like no it was Brendan okay that makes
sense if if he knew it was you Brendan
he wouldn't have gave a [ __ ]
and honestly dude he when he said he
said it he said it with a smile too I
don't like I think that that wasn't I
don't think that was a calculated thing
I think that was just because Dana White
has a big mouth and I'm sure he talks to
people jokingly like that all the time
and it was probably one of those things
where he's like all right and by the way
that was Brandon Schaub and he just was
like that makes sense guys have a go I
mean like it's one of those things any
one of us could have gotten caught off
guard I mean like I wasn't trying to be
super personal about it I was you know I
was saying a smart-ass thing about you
real quick just to remind her up on our
self-promotion or up on our teams
on our Teespring store we have we have
two on our way one for both of us oh
nice uh we have uh There's the link
there at our Teespring let's go to
revenge of assist.com and go to shop uh
I'll be your huckleby shirt is up and as
you notice that logo
never really trademarked it so um
ROTC and by the way just as a reminder
this meets the legal definition of
parity we've we've contacted our lawyers
and we're fine in this situation
um just in case Brandon wants to you
know when he's done suing drunk
YouTubers [ __ ] come after us
bro
you know what it's like fellas you know
you got that one friend who's a little
too aggressive when he hears when he
hears people being gay you you you're
the guy who said you were gay 40 times
bro
but he's a little too angry about him
you're like hmm that's weird right
like you're driving in your [ __ ]
Bronco with all the doors down someone's
like what's up gay boys
I'm not getting like whatever
oh that's that's hilarious you look gay
you look super gay you dress like a gay
guy you dress like you purposely take it
in the anus all the time this is funny
you can't get mad
because you like it your tight jeans the
reason you wear tight jeans jeans just
to show off your [ __ ] goods for all
the other gay guys yeah and then you
hang out with other gay guys if that
more Carly guy isn't gay I'll [ __ ]
eat an old shoe sucking [ __ ]
seriously sucking seriously too that's
hilarious your friend's like what the
[ __ ] dude
you're right man Jesus Brennan looks
like he's called people the F slur more
than us more than ever he's been in a
lot he's been in a locker room of a UF
[ __ ] of a [ __ ] UFC yeah probably
sleep bro I'm so mad yeah but you're
saying it to your boyfriend so you're
allowed
wait he did wear a mask all pandemic
right no no variant he's like I'm not a
mask guy and then monkey pox is taking
out the gays he starts rocking a mask
foreign
you know how I know you think dicks are
delicious I don't know bro whatever
you're [ __ ] your entire thing your
entire life is about dicks wasn't that a
stolen bit
yeah everything he does is stolen yeah
you know I know something it's not like
Grandma's Boy or yeah you know how you
know you know how I know you're gay
that's where that's from yes that's not
Grandma's Boy that's knocked up I
knocked up I might be not or Pineapple
Express or one of them [ __ ] up okay
you know how I know you're gay that's
the same joke he's doing yeah
foreign
hey Brendan you know how I know you're
gay even with all your UFC money and Joe
Rogan Fame you couldn't [ __ ] abroad from
trash Tuesday oh they're all saying 40
year old virgin whatever it was one of
those are the same Arrow movies all
those movies are the same
that's okay Brendan you know how I know
you're gay because every time you're on
stage you eat dicks that's true
bro I did nothing to you man was mind my
business having some fun
okay can somebody kids kids listen can I
say something here
no
or anything okay [ __ ] off can somebody
can somebody tell Chris Delia that
Brandon Schaub is trying to steal his
entire personality because at this point
it's Oh you mean like because he's doing
this stuff am I wrong because he Now
talks funny bro
but he is right are you trying to do
something he's about to do his Eminem
impression next he's like you know what
Dana I'm about to get litigious yeah you
want to get litigious well if it's it's
if it's Delia it's barely litigious but
yeah I'm with you
the UFC 279 I was going to say I hope he
uh follows Chris d'elia's career path
a lot of support though I appreciate it
it's where I get a lot of support people
are being nice to me like a lot of
support for the few haters
gotta talk about the
man
please go ahead
[ __ ] haters is that your stand-up
show yeah I wonder how much how much how
much how many minutes do you think Ryan
long has on the [ __ ] hate probably
zero minutes how many minutes do you
think Danny has on the heaters
oh [ __ ] haters for the few haters
that made fun the way he dresses at
whatever he is the only hater I care
about is Jamie hater so make fun of the
way he dresses that's us he's talked by
the way can I be clear he's talking
about us here he could pretend he's not
but I'll tell you something go look it
up we're we are your algorithm
years because I made fun of the way he
dresses at whatever he is 55 years old
uh they're like oh you're gonna make fun
of potato and designer jeans and wearing
cool shoes look at you dumbass
Daddy's go look at our video that is our
quote basically am I wrong
okay and by the way we didn't say you
wear cool fashionable clothes they're
not cool we said you look like an idiot
too
I've said this before but I'll say it
again you are dressed the way a single
mom dresses the kid of the guy who left
her um
I was like yeah [ __ ] the difference is
I've been a fuckboy since day one
one
crystallia wants his entire gimmick Mac
Brennan look man and I know that we're
the haters or whatever but I gotta tell
you man
you have to pick who you are you're 40
now
yeah and he can't he still can't figure
out if he's a baby face or a heel who
are you that's what it is right it's
like it's like he doesn't know it's like
when you see a badly booked wrestler and
you're like okay but one week they had
him come out and save like the main baby
face and he was a good guy and then the
next week he was like bullying and
beating up staff members backstage and
like you know what I mean like what are
we doing with this guy week in week one
one week he's like good guy one week
he's doing bad [ __ ] another one now I
don't even know what you are [ __ ]
Brian Danielson over here gave him four
different gimmicks in six weeks battle
cat in the rumble chat Rogan lit the
Brendan Fusion ran to Texas to avoid the
explosion it's very funny actually
I came out the womb first boy if he does
if he does a bane impression
he's gonna
you know I came out the womb with
[ __ ] skinny jeans dude listen I don't
dress like this because I hope you guys
think it's cool like he does I dress
like this because I like this I know
skinny jeans aren't in I know my dick's
in the front Row's face I know this
he's owning the fact that he sucks got
it see but the problem is even owning
the fact that you suck doesn't change
the fact that you [ __ ] suck I don't
mean to do that but I like the jeans
[Music]
can you see how much changes in my
pocket yes whatever dude
I was born a sneakerhead
he did it he did the he
guys oh you threw that headset he did he
did the thing by the way Merch this time
could actually attest I didn't see this
before the show because we were doing
Infowars so this is something I grabbed
he did the thing
he did the thing you know what the best
part is hey hey Royce you know what the
best part is what's the best part Virgie
it was a bad pain impression too I know
and by the bait impression should be the
easiest impression all you have to do is
first it's really not hard
I was born a sneakerhead you feel me
remember when Bane said you feel me
that was my favorite part when pain was
like that's right yeah only when God
Only When God said ashes then you have
my permission to die you feel me
you feel me homie
[Laughter]
tumble
my truck
Bruce Wayne nice guy I never met him
I was wondering what would break first
your spirit or your pick of the guy
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] the only joke on that stage
is Brendan
by the way we took your [ __ ]
throwaway joke and made it a hilarious
bit you [ __ ] hack God you suck
if mine and Dana's relationship was a
movie it'd be Shawshank Redemption shawl
by the way
shawl Shank Redemption can you let me
listen to his comedy please okay yes his
comment here about shoalshank Redemption
laughs
I like to tell you he got away from the
ladies you feel me
didn't get you know [ __ ] in the ass
all game [ __ ]
I best have poked through a Joe Rogan
poster and Brendan's cell for the whole
it's Joe Rogan bending over and the
holes in the ass the shawl Shank
Redemption I'd like to say effective I'd
like to tell you that Brendan fought
back the sisters from trash Tuesdays
I like to tell you that
I'll shake Redemption shawl shank that
that is our relationship in a nutshell
listen he's the evil Warden
I'm Andy defranio you think you're Andy
Dufresne I mean maybe you guys got
[ __ ] in the ass same amount of times
but that's about where the similarities
end first of all Andy Dufresne was able
to do math one
that was very funny merch
and number three
can we can we also just take a moment to
at least give Brendan some credit that
he may not be able to pronounce
Shawshank but he's said to frame
properly
but you know you know why because he's
never read it he's never read the word
he's never read the word he's seen the
movie a hundred times if you asked him
to spell Dufresne it would be a disaster
yes that would be Dufresne
do free
CEO
oh I crawled through some [ __ ] to get
away from that man to get to where I'm
at you can't root for the ward and go
the fun roots for the warden in that
movie
I do the warden's kid and yeah and I
root for the warden only because in this
movie it's a CTE terrible terrible
timing horrible podcast [ __ ] in it and
not a lovable guy that was just thrown
into a shitty situation you're the
warden do you hear that and you you know
you know what you are you know what you
are Brendan you're the warden and you
know what you're holding prisoner all of
Comedy so or comedy as you would say and
some of podcasts yeah look I don't
really know enough about Dana White to
even form an opinion of him to be honest
with you I think his Fighters get paid
like [ __ ] yeah I think he's probably a
hard ass and probably not always the
nicest guy in the world [ __ ] or whatever
but you're you're just a [ __ ] again
you're trying to be this is what like a
[ __ ] like a narcissist basically does
when they tell you a story
they're always either the hero or the
victim yeah they're never the bad guy
they're never like somebody that can at
least take partial responsibility and go
all right you know maybe I [ __ ] up a
little bit there it's you're always
either the victim or the [ __ ] hero
that's the only two things you can ever
tell a story from the perspective of you
started this Brendan you did by slinging
[ __ ] over the wall and you were like
well I was just talking about you you
basically accused Dana White and the
entire UFC of Fraud and you could
probably accused them of crimes and then
when uh he said whoever accused me of a
crime is a [ __ ] you know a
thick-headed [ __ ] [ __ ] idiot [ __ ]
yeah we should see her brain and then
somebody went by the way you're yelling
about Pat matudik or whatever it was
actually Brennan's job and he went nah
all right that makes sense yeah [ __ ]
idiot you're the one that started this
fellas you want to test to see if your
girl is right or died you want to test
see if your girl's the one try to [ __ ]
one of the trash Tuesday people in your
F-150 in a parking lot if she stays with
you she's right or die you mean the one
like Neo or the one like Billy Gunn
I love Billy gunman that was a bad era
do this for me when you leave here
tonight put on Shawshank Redemption
Shawshank
literally one of the best movies of all
time what I've never heard of this film
99 of Rotten Tomatoes classic it's a
[ __ ] classic put on sauce that's the
one guy that gave him a bad reviewers
who's the one guy that hates Josh anchor
that was the warden this movie is the
warden
she hadn't seen in the first place right
communist but that's whatever no you're
not there right not here nor there
you should move to Russia anyways so
Russia's in Communists put on Shawshank
Redemption watch it all the way through
and when you watch all the way through
look at your girl no what'd you think if
she goes
it was good I just don't like what
happened to the war did y'all that would
never happen this joke is a terrible
premise you're trying to connect Dana
White to a warden of a movie with you
can't even tangentially connect it to
him it's it's not the same it's not the
same thing because in Shawshank
Redemption Andy Dufresne didn't go out
there and talk [ __ ] about the warden
over the PA and then the warden started
[ __ ] with him because then if you saw
Shawshank and he did that a lot of us
watching the movie would go okay but you
[ __ ] award in his face I would stay
out of the world you weren't an innocent
bystander brand you went up there and
you [ __ ] on the warden's desk
sociopath Jesus
sociopath okay you know sociopath
you could even watch Game of Thrones if
you've never seen it watch Game of
Thrones is that all you know Brendan is
TV shows ever seen Game of Thrones ever
heard of this one
have you ever seen entered popular thing
here because sometimes when I'm watching
popular thing it reminds me of certain
person
wait right binge watch it this week with
your girl to find out you just discover
the the [ __ ] Universal theorem for
comedy well let me tell you something
buddy I'm taking online I'm taking
online classes at the San Francisco
comedy college so I'll have you know I'm
learning a thing or two
this is [ __ ] the San Francisco comedy
College shouldn't [ __ ] uh in nail
salon you know what I would love more if
at once he's done Brennan just drops a
mic in big day lion has to go there pick
it up and wipe it off and like grab his
bags and like walk behind Ben and you
know where are we going boss what are we
doing boss I think he carries these bags
yeah I'm pretty sure he does but he kind
of he kind of like looks at the crowd
for a second like kind of like
shamefully and then he sniffs the
microphone before he waits he does he
goes
thank you
yeah
[ __ ] one through it when it gets done
you go man some people think it's the
greatest TV series of all time what do
you think babes y'all it's not breaking
bad it was good I wish the white walkers
won you know what I'm saying better than
bran yeah I would have honestly the way
that show ended made me
kind of sad the white walkers didn't win
serial killer [ __ ] serial killer
there'll be roots for date of life I'm
like bad at him though I don't give a
[ __ ] hey I found the [ __ ] Evan M
two stars on Rotten Tomatoes
look I
know that it's only predictable
melodramatic and cliched because
everyone else copied it it's still
predictable melodramatic and cliched
what a miserable person though I mean he
has miserable but all right all right
man the white walkers won you know what
I'm saying serial killer [ __ ] serial
killer
there'll be roots for date of life I'm
like bad at him though
honestly I don't but I root for him
against you yeah I think more people
just root against you yeah
you know how many P you know how many
people rude used to root against the
Patriots you know how many people just
root against Tom Brady
you know look at the end of the day
actually no I mean once you shed that
dirty filthy Jersey everybody likes him
you know that's a really good point
because even people that like woke up
you know exactly New England yeah